I wouldn't class myself as talented I
think you have to work for talent you
have to like I couldn't really play
guitar or sing and I learned how to do
both and like you couldn't rewrite song
and then I learned how to do it I think
it's all but I think persistence is
worth more than Talent
I came to London where and was not the
best singer songwriter or the best like
performer in the scene that I was in but
the more and more you work at something
you you you give yourself no choice but
to get better so I think yeah
persistence for me was the key and
that's what I tell any kid nowadays that
comes up and says how how do I become a
performer and I'm like it don't worry if
you can't really sing you can't really
play like I couldn't really when I first
started out but I was persistent with it
like I never thought I'd be doing
anything else I never thought I'd be
playing stadiums but I always thought
I'd make a living doing music even if it
was just playing a pub showing getting
100 quid at the end of the night I
always knew that was possible so I just
I never had any other plans